hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar latest clinical
results in oncology drug management I am
Judy or Oracle a Bert's and I'll be
moderating this session today's
educational webinar is presented by lab
roots the leading scientific social
networking website and provide our
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
this presentation has been approved for
continuing educational credits if you
want to obtain the credit please click
on the get your free CME credits button
located in the lower left of your screen
this will take you to the continuing
education page where you can select
speaker click on the CEC Emmy button and
it will take you through the process to
obtain your certification let's get
started you can post questions to the
speaker during the presentation while
they're fresh in your mind to do so
simply type them into the Q&A box which
will open when you click the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to get to
as many as we can and we'll follow up if
we don't have time today to enlarge the
slide window click on the screen icon in
the lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you experience technical
problems seeing or hearing the
presentation just click on the support
button found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the green Q&A
button at lower left I now present
today's speaker salje Salmoni PhD
founder and chief scientific officer of
salad ex biomedical incorporated which
is dedicated to the development of TDM
in the field of oncology and companion
diagnostics valid x has supported
numerous clinical studies supporting the
use of TDM in oncology and has become
the leading force in oncology TDM dr.
Salmoni has more than 25 years
experience in healthcare and medical
device industry prior to founding fell
attacks it was vice president of
research and development for roche
diagnostics where he was responsible for
north american research and development
efforts for the laboratory systems
division after some low needs efforts
during his 17-year tenure roche resulted
in you launch of seven
major region product lines comprised of
more than 70 FDA approved products and
more than 200 instrument applications
after Salmoni is well published in the
field with more than 70 peer-reviewed
publications numerous book chapters and
he is also a holder of 42 issued us
patents to learn more about dr. some
money click on the still image in the
right corner for more information or go
to the lab group site dr. Salmoni will
now his presentation thank you it's
pleasure to talk to all of you today I
we've been um I've been involved with
cancer TDM for the past o 12 years or so
and there's a lot of exciting results
that have recently come out and I'd like
to review them today but before I get
into the latest clinical data I just
want to give a little background con on
what what has led to this development of
clinical work first of all I want to say
that you know getting the right dosage
of drug is really not new Paracelsus who
was the father of modern day
pharmacology suggested that dose really
does matter and that was back in the
1500s and unfortunately the alchemist
didn't agree with him and they ran him
out of town and eventually they found
and murdered outside of city in
Switzerland it's never come to that
extent with me but sometimes when you
bring up a change of medical practice
you do get some a lot of flack so the
whole value proposition of those
management is is nothing new it's in TDM
this has been done for years and
transplantation and anti epileptics and
things like that we want to get the
docent in the right optimal range
it's if it's too high there's excessive
toxicity and if it's too low you might
might think that the patient is really
tolerating the drug well but in fact in
many cases they may be getting too low
of a dose and why why is this the case
well the way many cancer and most cancer
drugs are dosed today is it's based on
body surface area okay and that was a
formula that was developed in 1916 and
it was never it was never developed to
fine tune the exposure in the individual
it was developed to know the difference
when you were going from say a rabbit to
a mouse or to a primate species to
adjust um give some type of ballpark
figure as to what the dose from
different animal species would be there
was this dis formula in the 1950s was
adapted to cancer drugs with really
without a lot of scientific evidence and
it's really stuck it's become a it's
become an artifact of older type of
research and and there's many scientific
papers that show that that it is really
not a good way a good metric to get the
right dose in each patient and as I
mentioned TDM is the standard of care
and transplantation and antibiotic drugs
and the entire collective drugs next and
as I mentioned is this a fair body of
evidence that has shown that really this
this some way of dosing using body
surface area is really not accurate and
a lot of people have suggested that
looking at the exposure the drug would
be a much better way of
watching it this is a study done by the
group in Amsterdam and they looked at
the most commonly used chemotherapy
drugs and they dosed all these patients
based on body surface area and they
showed that there's a coefficient of
variation generally above thirty percent
in between thirty percent and up to
seventy percent and and and you know
this is one of the reasons why I'm you
know not everybody metabolizes the drug
in the same way and you know it leads to
a good deal of variation so some
patients are getting too much of the
drug and some patients are getting too
little of the drug and there's many
factors that influence it you know we
hear a lot about genetics and genetics
does play a key role in the variability
you know different genotypes can can
really make a profound difference in the
exposure in the individual but it's not
the only reason males and females
metabolize the drugs differently often
older people sometimes a slow
metabolizers poly drug interaction
there's kidney function there's liver
function and so you cannot predict the
level of a drug or the exposure of the
drug in an individual just by nearly
looking at patients genotype and so what
we like to say is that by looking at the
active drug in the patient you're
looking at the phenotype which is a
combination of all the various
parameters that make a difference in the
drug exposure and this is a lovely
example and just look at the left-hand
figure there Cabo platinum is one of the
few chemotherapy drugs that are
routinely monitored or orton routinely
tired to a
exposure level and this is the case in
point if we look at the left hand slide
here and in the yellow highlight oops if
you look at the y axis has the
likelihood of an event and the x axis
has the exposure level and if you look
at the line with the triangles in it
that that is response rate and what this
shows you is that at a low a UC at two
or three you're not getting very high of
a response rate and then when you bring
the AUC up to about five to six you're
getting an optimal response rate and any
a UC or any exposure beyond five or six
you really aren't getting any more
benefit that's the first thing the
second thing is the other lines that you
see or toxicity so when you go up in
exposure you're not getting any more
benefit but you're increasing the
toxicity and that this work was done by
mellower gone and jor-el back in the
1990s and they identified really what I
would call this is the sweet spot where
between five and six where the drug
concentration should be tighter to and
it's been the standard of care in cancer
our research or in cancer treatment
today that's when a patient goes on Cabo
platinum they doctors will measure the
creatinine clearance and adjust the dose
of drug based on creatinine clearance
and the creatinine clearance is a very
good metric for the exposure and so this
is a good example of how TDM does work
in oncology and but for the most part
other oncology drugs aren't
dressed in this manner ok so that's the
introduction now I'd like to get into
some studies that have recently been
done and i'll just give a little
background on on this first of all
5-fluorouracil it's the it's really the
base drug that's used in treatment of
colorectal cancer and it's part of the
regimen for full fury for fox and full
fox with biologicals and this was a
study that was done in in the US on 357
patients and there's been a lot of work
done to show that the target level
proper target level 45 floral uracil has
an aec value of 20 to 30 and as you can
see in the study that a large percentage
of patients in fact the majority of
patients were below the target range
between four and 19 auc eunuchs and
about ten to fifteen percent of the
patients were above and this is not the
first study that has shown this up with
5-fluorouracil treatment in colorectal
cancer the majority of patients are
really being given suboptimal doses
albeit there are patients that are also
given high doses and this is a an early
study that was published in 2008 it was
by Eric gamlin it appeared in journal
Clinical Oncology it was a randomized
study where are made people received the
drug dose based on body surface area and
then on be it was TDM PK guided dosing
ok and i use TDM and PK guided dosing
interchangeably ok and if you look at
this this is a snapshot at three months
into the treatment y axis is number of
patients x axis is
the dose that was given in order to
achieve the target level so an army of
course they had traditional dosing and
all the patients were receiving 1500
milligrams per meter squared but look
look at arm be okay where the patients
had their doses adjusted according to
their exposure you could see that the
majority of patients okay had those
changes in order to achieve the target
level in fact eighty five percent of the
patients received those modifications to
achieve the target level next slide this
is another study that was done oh no
this is this is out of the same study so
what did all this dose adjustment mean
for for on be well first of all the
toxicity was reduced considerably and it
was statistically significant it went
from eighteen percent down the four
percent diarrhea and hematologic
toxicity decreased as well as mucositis
and what was us really quite quite nice
is that the response rate came almost
doubled in the PK guided dosing on it
was thirty-four percent also overall
survival at two years went from thirteen
percent in the conventional armed with
twenty-eight percent in the in the dose
adjustment now this this was a nice
study but there was a lot of criticism
on it because it wasn't with a currently
used regimen especially a regimen that
would be used in the US a later study
came out on full fox6 which is one of
the most common leaves our regiment and
the same type of data was seen first of
all about fifty percent of the patients
needed those increases and about thirty
percent of the patients needed those
decreases toxicity was reduced as you
can see in the this was not a randomized
study but there was a a parallel on by
the way and that was the blue vs a ghost
arm it was 39 patients and the
kom had 118 patients but you can see
from this data that that there was a
substantial reduced reduction of
diarrhea or mucositis and the response
rate was was very very favorable it went
from forty six percent in the BSA arm to
seventy percent in the TV mr and it also
the progression free survival went from
10 months to 16 months and overall
survival went to 28 months so this was
further proof that by doing TDM not only
were you able to reduce toxicity but
because for the higher dose intensity
for those patients that were initially
getting a lower exposure the higher dose
intensity salted in better efficacy
another study that came out this was a
US based study walk FL gary was the
principal investigator on this and it
was only done with a small part of a
small portion of patients versus
historical controls but it was stage 2 3
can't Telegraph metal cans on stage for
and what I wanted to point out here is
that this was in the adjuvant area and
we're looking at a disease-free survival
and if we look at the right hand craft
there or right hand figure you can see
that the disease free survival over a
36-month period was considerably better
in and it was statistically significant
in the PK guided on versus the DSA this
some next study is 5-fluorouracil study
that was done in Germany in a a
community setting this was a and and
what happened this was the it was done
it was in 87 Center study and it was
done with 80 metastatic colorectal
cancer patients and they looked at and
the exposure and dose adjustment in the
most commonly used regiment in Germany
and that is the aio regimen the full fox
regimen and the full fox6 regiment the
dose adjustment algorithm that was used
was published by cal date in the
oncologist about three years ago and
again the target range was 20 to 30
milligrams h/m that's the AUC
designation and depending on how close
you were to the target range the dose
was adjusted accordingly if you were
above the target range of 32 34 it was a
ten percent adjustment if you were above
target range of 40 it was down not just
those was adjusted down by thirty
percent on the other hand if you were
below the target range the dose was
adjusted anywhere between ten percent
and twenty-five percent so as I
mentioned they were actually
seventy-seven patients enrolled and 16
were treated with the aio regimen full
26 world with the full fox6 regimen and
the full folks regimen is 33 what we
wanted to see here was how the
oncologists were following the dose
adjustment directions and this is a
correlation curve between the suggested
dose and actual goes and actually the
correlation was was quite good when we
asked the doctor to increase the dose
7777 percent of them adjusted it in the
right direction in using the suggested
algorithm no change ninety-four percent
followed the protocol and when we asked
them to decrease those seventy percent
follow the protocol exactly so that's
pretty good compliance and that's one of
the concerns with doing TDM is to ensure
that you know that the oncologist is
complying with the dose adjustment
algorithm and these are the results of
these are all the patients this is a dot
plot on this and again in this study
sixty-four percent of the patients were
under dosed at the beginning at the
first dose thirty-three percent were at
the target level and about three percent
were above the target level primary
endpoint of this study was to see if by
cycle three and four that the patients
that were able to achieve target level
and we did achieve the primary endpoint
you can see by cycles three and four
after risk repeated those adjustments
the majority of patients were and the
average patients were in the target
range let's look at cycle three ok so at
cycle three the mean auc was 23 and
standard deviation was six and
sixty-five percent of the patients were
in the target range and sixteen or
twenty five percent were below and ten
percent were above so by doing this
using this dose adjustment algorithm we
were able to put more patients into the
target range by cycles two and three and
the way this is done
um and I should have said this from the
beginning the way this is done is that
the patient is given an initial dose of
5-fu according to body surface area and
the sample is taken any time after 18
hours after the beginning of the
effusion and may you see is calculated
then the next time the patient comes in
for say their second cycle a third cycle
the doctor adjusts the dose according to
the previous exposure um this is just a
reflection at cycle 4 of the
distribution of doses needed to achieve
the target range and this is very
similar to the data that I showed you
from the gamblin study in 2008 there is
a wide range of dose dosing or dose
intensity needed to achieve the target
level and then this shows you the
distribution in terms of toxicity and
that was a secondary endpoint in the
study with even though we had an
increase of dose intensity there was
some patients that were above dose that
had to be given a lower dose and
compared to historical controls there
was reduction of toxicity the toxicity
related to a 5-fu mainly mucositis
nausea and diarrhea so not only were we
able to get the drug exposure in the
right ranges but we are also able to
show that we were reducing toxicity
another parameter that we looked at was
tumor markers and I'm you know got
oncologists often use tumor markers to
just assess whether the chemotherapy is
working
they see an increase in tumor markers
they may change the regimen or change
the dosing and in this case what I want
to point out is that in about eighty
four percent of cases the patients
either had a decrease in tumor antigen
level or tumor antigen level was stable
both for CA 19-9 and CEA and so the
control of the disease was you know
upwards of eighty percent 88 possibly
eighty-four percent and this is
consistent with other dose adjustment
studies that we've seen where they've
done radiology to check out the what
they did the imaging to check out the
response rate so in conclusion from this
study we the primary endpoint was
achieved after four cycles and the peak
a guided dosing resulted in really
significantly more patients falling
within the target range we were able to
reduce toxicity and again we showed in
this study as in previous studies that
the majority of patients getting
colorectal cancer treatment with 5-fu
majority of them get sub optimal dosing
based on just body surface area and
further this was a demonstration
community clinic type of practice and
then it demonstrated that you could do
those adjustment in a community setting
and get significant results ok I want to
switch now to paclitaxel we just come
this is a study also sponsored by salad
acts as
well as the Caesar organization in
Austria and it was an investigator led
study paclitaxel pharmacology again the
variability of of exposure of paclitaxel
when you dose based on body surface area
is quite large and the number of
investigators over the years have shown
that the critical peak a parameter is
time above threshold ok and the
threshold concentration is point zero 5
micro molar a target range for the
optimal time above threshold is 26 to 31
hours meaning that a patient's blood
level should of point 05 micromolar
should be beat should be at that level
between 26 and 31 hours if that if it's
above 31 hours there's more toxicity and
if there's if it's below 26 hours
there's a lack of efficacy and that that
that blood level was based on
hematologic toxicity the there have been
limited sample models generated this was
done by Marcus yoga who's a leader in
this field of paclitaxel pharmacology
and what you do is you take on one
sample between 18 and 30 hours and you
can calculate the primerica threshold
now major toxicities and the two major
toxicities with paclitaxel that one has
to be aware of is is neutropenia and
also neurotoxicity now oncologists tell
me that the neutropenia is something
that they can deal with because some
there's this um
cell stimulating factors that that if
somebody is suffering into peenya they
can be given growth factors and and that
will help stabilize them the toxicity
that a lot of oncologists are very
concerned with is the neurotoxicity
there are no drugs available to prevent
it and there are limited treatment
treatments available to try to mitigate
the effects of of neurotoxicity and it
appears quite often and it can last far
beyond the treatment cycles this was a
randomized to arm study patients that we
looked at were non-small cell lung
cancer patients it was three weekly
paclitaxel with carboplatin of course
carbaryl platinum was titrated to in aec
aimer had conventional dosing and army
had TDM or PK guided dosing target range
was between 26 and 31 hours the primary
endpoint was reduction of neutropenia
and secondary endpoints were neuropathy
and tumor response progression-free
survival and overall survival this is
how the randomization occurred again
there were altogether 386 patients in
the study this pie in azamgarh fact this
is the largest PK guided dosing study
ever done in the field of oncology ok
are there actually there were only two
others ever reported one from the
methotrexate back in 1998 and the 54
uracil 1 by gamma in 2008 okay so this
is a dose adjustment algorithm and I
just want you to focus on the top part
foot for the first four
glance the if you look before in the PK
guided arm patients had their dosage
ested initially based on age and gender
so if a female would receive a lower
dose that than a male this females are
known to metabolize more slowly and the
older and an older patient metabolizes
it more slowly so there was an initial
dose adjustment based on these two
parameters and then in the end if you
look at the lower right hand box it was
a dose adjustment chart based on on the
levels that they had and in every cycle
they were adjusted accordingly this is
the distribution of paclitaxel dosing
okay so if we look at the commit the
dimensional arm is green and the PK on
is red and that are in JAMA is the
initial pharmacology dose adjustment
based on age and gender and so what you
could see is that the starting dose of
this were in the conventional arm the
median starting dose was 200 milligrams
per meter squared and that's the
conventional way of dosing it and the
median dosing in the PK guided arm was
170 now if we go all the way to cycle 6
what you can see here is that in the
conventional on people stay that that an
initial dose of from 200 actually the
median was 198 but in the PK guided arm
in order to achieve the target level the
median was 133 and then take a look at
the distribution of the doses that were
needed in order to achieve the target
level and again this is a reflection of
the PK variability normal PK variability
that one sees that each patient really
had to have a unique dose in order to
achieve their target level and so what
we see is that over the course of the
study there was about a thirty percent
lower dose intensity in the PK on now
remember when I showed you five floral
yourself the majority of patients seem
to be getting too low of the dose with
paclitaxel treatment in non-small cell
lung cancer it seems that more patients
are getting too high of a dose this is
just whether what what PK a guided
dosing in and what percentage of
patients if we look at the peak a guided
arms in this in this table you see that
sixty-two percent of the patients needed
dose adjustment downward and eighteen
percent of the patients needed the dose
adjustments to be increased so while the
majority of patients were getting too
high over those there was some patients
that were getting under toast and this
is a distribution in the PK guided on
the shaded area in this figure is the
target area and what you can see is that
there were a great deal of patience
above the target area and also a
substantial amount below and by doing PK
guided dosing in each subsequent cycle
you could see that we were able to
really get most of the patients below
the below the highest target level and
that that was the aim for study and what
else what else can I show oh um and and
each point represents the patient and
the reason why we have less patience in
the bycicle six is that because
non-small cell lung cancer and there was
the you know many in patients deceased
before the mfa cycle or dropped out of
treatment and what did what did all this
dose adjustment do in terms of toxicity
well the primary endpoint of entropy Nia
wasn't achieved there was a reduction in
neutropenia but it was leaning toward
significance but it wasn't significant
there was a sixteen percent reduction
but what was significant and and this
was very surprising was that there was a
30-30 nine percent reduction and it was
statistically significant of grade 2 or
higher toxicity and a seventy-eight
percent reduction of grade 3 neural
neuropathy and so this this is um this
was very nice to see that because as I
mentioned before earlier the neuropathy
is a very difficult toxicity to deal
with and by doing this those adjustments
you can substantially reduce this type
of toxicity the that's fine to reduce
the toxicity tissue and lowering the
dose intensity but the question is by
lowering this toxicity by lowering the
dose intensity what happens to if we
look at at the response rate there was
really no difference between stable
disease or complete or partial response
there was us up some difference but it
wasn't statistically significant for
response rates and then progression-free
survival between the two arms was very
similar you can see that left-hand graph
an overall survival again was very
similar between arms
so what some we have here in the
conclusions is that PK guided dosing did
result in a clinically relevant
reduction of neuropathy compared with
standard dosing and that the lower dose
intensity of about thirty percent did
not significantly change the efficacy
and this is the first time that this
type of work has been shown with
paclitaxel and again the reduction of
neuropathy is pretty significant in the
last study that I wanted to talk about
is a similar study to what I just showed
you from Germany but this one is being
done in shanghai at shanghai pulmonary
hospital again it's a randomized
treatment that these are interim results
they were presented at ASCO in June and
the results are very similar so this is
the second such study using paclitaxel
and carbo platinum and looking at
toxicity as the major endpoint so far
this study is supposed to accrue 300
patients thus far it's accrues 155
patients and in this study we looked at
the exposure both in the DSA arm and the
PK guided dose adjustment and again the
red is the conventional dosing and the
green is the PK guided dosing here in
this study there was no initial
pharmacology adjustment for gender or
age and so if you look at the green and
the red you'll see in cycle one that
they had very similar exposure and most
of the exposure was above the target
range and then this was a
or cycle treatment and as you can see in
the PK guided arm patients had lower and
lower dose exposure as each cycle went
on okay now what did this mean in terms
of toxicity and again what we're seeing
is a reduction not clinically
significant of neutropenia but we are
seeing a trend very similar to the CPAC
study that I just went over with lower
reduction of neuropathy greater the
grade 1 greater than great and a forty
three percent reduction in greater than
grade two neuropathy this is very very
early data but it the trends are the
same and you know there and what this is
doing is validating that dose adjustment
algorithm is actually being effective
and the table to reduce toxicity we have
some data on response not
progression-free survival or overall
survival but we have some imaging data
again showing that with all of this dose
reduction in the dose adjustment arm
there is no difference in response rate
so the conclusion of this study again
this is just interim analysis so we
don't have statistical significance here
but this verified what the seatac study
has also shown that there's wide
variability and exposure when you're
being dosed based on body service area
the dose algorithm was effective and
modifying the exposure and the overall
dose intensity was reducing between
twenty and thirty percent and it seemed
and again similar to the
back study there was a lower incidence
of toxicities without reducing the
efficacy this study should be finished
oh I would say in another three or four
months and that's really all I had to
say and I'm you know I'll take questions
at this stage thank you dr. Salmoni for
your presentation a quick reminder for
audience on how it submit questions
simply type them in the Q&A box found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
will try to get to as many as we can and
will follow up if we don't have time
today and your first question is could
you mention again what are the
parameters for PK based dosing what are
the parameters for PK days dosing um I'm
not quite clear 450 the DM on the
question but let me go through 45 floral
uracil it's called area under the curve
auc arm and the desert and the what area
under the curve is milligrams per hour
or milligrams times hours per liter and
so that's you know that what's what's
the critical peak a parameter is in
terms of paclitaxel it's not aec but
it's time above certain threshold a
certain concentration threshold and in
in the case of paclitaxel it was 26 to
31 hours yeah did I answer the question
properly I would say that you did
definitely all right maybe will be a
follow-up question okay right you are I
just I just want to remind people again
how to spin that question so you type
them in the Q&A box
which is found by clicking on the green
Q&A button located at the lower left of
the presentation window and so a message
of Spanx has come in from one of
listeners so if there are no more
questions I would once again like to
thank you dr. Salmoni for your
presentation do you have any final
comments to share with us today um no I
just hope I gave the audience a few
about the necessity that really if
somebody's being treated with
chemotherapy agents that you know
current methods just not are not very
good and really exposure is an extremely
important aspect and you know we hear so
much about personalized medicine and
doing TDM in oncology is really a very
significant step towards personalizing
those on a patient by patient basis and
thanks for your attention oh um a
question has come in now hope you have
the moment to answer it okay so how how
do you find document let's see how do
you find documents where chemotherapy
regimens have were written about in the
AUC I hope I stated that garmi the [ __ ]
yeah you mean publications the
literature's is some really that the
literature is full of publications
showing documenting on target levels for
a you see so if you are interested in
finding the publications like go to
PubMed and you know type in five floral
uracil pharmacokinetics or
5-fluorouracil PK guided dose adjustment
and and you'll see that is quite quite a
number of articles that have come out
just with 500 year or so there must be
at least 20 or 30 studies demonstrating
the variability of 5-fluorouracil and
we'll tackle eat axel is probably 20 to
30 studies as well so the pharmacology
literatures is really full of the truck
this type of work ok and have another
one for you how long is the duration or
time point to check UK when you perform
TK based dosing ok so 45 total yourself
um generally the regimens go for 46
hours and so what we like to say is you
should collect between 18 hours and 42
hours you take 11 point ok and you have
to take it from the vain because the
patient still is having the drug pumped
into their port and the reason why you
don't go you know collect a point closer
to forty six hours and sometimes the
pumps run out and and so if the pump run
value you really can't take the sample
for for the to get a proper value the
patient has to be undergoing infusion
with 5-fu so it's so in short you have
to take it either the second day or four
hours before the end of the fusion on
the third day with paclitaxel they get a
three hour push of the drug in the
beginning and then they have to come
back the next day and anywhere between
18 hours and 30 hours they need to have
a sample taken and so these limited
sampling strategies have been developed
and they've been shown to be a very
effective way of estimating the exposure
in the patient ok well thank you again
dr. simoni and I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions just
reminder if you wish to obtain
credit for today's session please click
on me get your free cme credit button
located in the lower left of your screen
this will take you to the continuing
education page where you can select a
speaker click on the CEC Emmy button and
be guided through the process to obtain
your certification this webcast can be
viewed on demand through april first
2016 lab roots will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time bye